so dark so dark it's in here
Oh more businesses
are you nineties
lock is very courier
karora got so many prison cells
No what am I
[ __ ] keep funny dead ends and nothing to
break dead ends
where is she where did she go all the
girlies
now I'm out there just making things
worse look this is no place for a young
girl all by herself she could be hurt or
worse there's no telling what horrors
await down there
oh oh maybe that wasn't a douche after
all
mom was here we go he always appears we
cool bro just picked up [ __ ] fare
okay we're cool
maybe it's a bro after all
see is the shipper made no sense but
missus
I get to refill my oil it's good oh it
was only a little whatever
so there was that was it
oh wait I can go back to the other room
now too bad I can't find it I remember
walking
or what oh yeah I could just follow
something tells me I shouldn't go there
let's do it anyway
I don't remember
closer oh yeah it I can use this now
I got a feeling the bros gonna come up
he's nothing
was here right no it was here
it's good
Oh
ah I don't want to go down there however
I see [ __ ] do it moving that orb was
like pushing a star in the night sky out
it it wasn't supposed to happen the
shadow isn't some vengeful spirit it is
the universe catching up with itself
well what do you know oh this is narrow
where did I come from
there's a light coming from
Oh
axor appeared here I would have liked I
fell
oh of course one is a certain death and
the other one is wait what's that rhyme
oh it's in Swedish Oh blue doula DAF
kinkle karna cough cough Elana Allah
dawn the doula tough kids left I was
probably wrong anyway but it doesn't
matter
oh well that was useful the hell let's
[ __ ] get in
as long as that disgusting guru doesn't
appear cool
all right
alright [ __ ] move
and we're cool I rat what [ __ ] are we we
are at the storage why not I'm gonna run
out of all you
gotta like one of these up so I remember
where I came from
what is that
oh is that so scary
oh there's someone up there bro monster
was that the kitchen storage storage
already relate up already to lit up
means you're dead never good news
never ever all right
oh [ __ ] haters gonna hate
friends home love because what's bad
is he safe
well it's for his own good
nice bread by the way
all right let's read this second of
August 1839 I have arrived at the
village of altstadt it's a haven in the
midst of a vast forest of the last stop
before my final destination castle
brennenburg
it's late in the evening and the
outrider who has been with the coaches
it's Bremen advised me to wait until
morning before I venture further
I've arranged for a bed at deir mula the
villages own angular and of now waiting
for the Sun to rise I try to sleep but
as I close my eyes I see the men who
fell victim in London my fear and shame
forces me to witness the same scenes
over and over they are dead because of
me
Suba we ready
how's my son in doing there'll be enough
time bro be cool
I wanna play this game anymore haha oh
my god oh my god oh my holy [ __ ] that
was ah jesus [ __ ] christ
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
oh Jesus Jesus oh my oh holy [ __ ] this
game is gonna give me a heart attack
that was the most horrible thing ever
holy [ __ ] I can't do this anymore
oh my god oh my god oh my god ah sorry
no no I got a